india has been one of the world's
economic success stories
the country is home to some of the
world's richest people
and millions have been lifted out of
poverty
but the pandemic could change that covet
19 hits everyone the poor
as well as the rich and famous
with the world's third highest number of
confirmed covit 19 cases
more than 2 million experts are warning
of rising poverty at the same time
india cannot afford another lockdown
leaving the country between a rock
and a hard place
[Music]
welcome to your copy 19 special here on
dw news i'm monica johnson berlin good
to have you with us
so india is in focus today it of course
is one of the most
populated countries in the world and one
of the hardest hit by the coronavirus
pandemic
the country's strict lockdown may have
saved many lives
but it also robbed many of their
livelihoods and that's where two
teenagers from delhi come in
as early as march they set up a national
hotline to direct
food and medicine to people in need
helping some 70
000 to date and demand for aid is not
ebbing away
how many people seven people
seven seven people are two families in
[Music]
oklahoma
and her twin sister asis get a dozen
calls per day
the girls have set up a telephone
helpline in delhi they use it to
distribute food
and medicine the coronavirus pandemic
has plunged hundreds
of thousands of indians into joblessness
and poverty
when the lockdown started there were so
many people out there who'd lost their
jobs their income and they didn't even
have
enough money or resources to get the
most basic necessities like food or
medicine
and we were so done tweeting
and asking the authorities to take
action so we thought we'd
create this helpline the twins mother
helps finance the initiative as six they
say that good doing works is important
to them
you know in my religion we always put
aside money to be spent for charity
and well it's one of the worst crisis
ever any of our generations including my
parents they've ever seen
the twins mother also brings food
medicine and masks
to delhi's outlying districts tens of
thousands of migrant workers live in
this settlement
when her daughters got the first call
for help people here had gone hungry for
five days straight
we work in the fields but no one's
hiring us anymore my husband sold
vegetables
what are we supposed to live on what are
we supposed to eat
the schools are closed we can't send our
children to class anymore
taking care of all these people here is
too big a task for their initiative
their mother wonders why the government
doesn't help
i don't know why everyone sees this
except the government
these people should have been
rehabilitated long time ago but they
have no business to be here
and suffering like this a new call has
come in for the twins
they've already helped feed 50 000
families in over 30 cities across the
country
now flour sugar and rice is heading to a
family
but the demand continues
so let's talk a little bit more about
the pandemic in india and i'm joined now
by peter
melee's resident representative to india
at the
normally in delhi uh but currently in
germany and that is due to the pandemic
uh pedrime
just briefly uh what prompted you to
come back to germany
yes good afternoon first what prompted
me it is as you mentioned the
coronavirus situation in india it's
increasing daily we have like now 62 000
was the latest
figure of increase today a total of 2.2
million
but that is not the only reason it was
recommended also by the german embassy
and most german institutions called
their stuff back because
the key point was that there is not
enough medical
supplies there is not treatment
guaranteed in case and that's why nobody
wanted to take the risk and said so
please come back for the time being okay
so so you're back in germany now but of
course millions of millions of indians
are in
india and we do see uh rising case
numbers there nevertheless the
government
wants to open the economy again can
india afford that
well i would say it's they try to find a
balance between
life and livelihood what they have done
first they had the strongest lockdown
ever
in the world and that was there to
protect the lives of the people that
they did not get infected
the consequence was that many lost their
jobs especially the
migrant workers and had no income and
their livelihood was taken away
so they are opening yes on the one side
on the other side
they are doing lockdowns in selected
areas where you have lots of infected
people
you can call that a smart lockdown they
have certain containment zones they put
it
in red orange green like a traffic light
and try to control it there very tough
but the rest
to be opened more and to look into the
safety measures the typical ones keeping
social distance varying masks all of
that if you go into any shopping center
you're controlled
your temperature is taken you should you
have a mask you have to sanitize your
hands otherwise you can't get in
so they take measures also in the
villages but
on the other side see that they have to
come up with the economy they can't
afford to
lock down india longer going by those
those measures that you just described
which are very reminiscent of what we do
in here in europe as well of course
uh do you get the feeling that delhi has
the pandemic under control
well i think no country really with such
large figures
has the pandemic under control they try
to control as far as they can
i expect that maybe in august we have
the peak in india
and figures might go slightly down you
also have the government
influencing the countryside because the
migrant workers that is the thing took
the
the the infections from the cities when
they went back
to their villages but you have strong
control mechanisms
in the villages too where they very much
listen to the elders
and the elders are advised to enforce
those social
measures and those those hygiene
measures what i have
mentioned and people coming from delhi
they're coming they're also asked to go
into home current in for some time so
they try
to control the government also tries to
have financial measures for those who
are affected of it that starts from food
packages for those who were on the way
but it's also that like the bankruptcy
law has been
suspended tax payments have been
suspended
all other things so they try to ease the
situation for those who have a financial
burden out of the situation
all right peter president representative
to india at the conrad
currently here in germany but talking
about the pandemic
in india thank you so much for your time
and of course so a lot of measures are
in place but
do they reach everyone well not
necessarily and so often the crisis is
proving hardest for those already
living at the margins of society like
the street kids in delhi
fifteen-year-old rustam sometimes likes
to watch tv in this dimly lit room he
calls home
which he shares with some 50 people this
room is one of the many shelters that
houses
countless homeless families like his own
who live on the streets
many such families were given space in
these shelters after the nationwide
lockdown was announced to curb the
spread of coven 19.
many though are still out on the streets
with his father in poor health it has
fallen on rustam
the oldest of all siblings to earn for
the whole family
before the lockdown rustam like other
street children
did odd jobs to support his family after
going to a nearby local school
before the lockdown i used to go for
rack picking at the railway station
after that i sold tea at a nearby park i
also sold toys and corn cobs
later i started selling water bottles
and cold drinks
the children may face many problems for
example they can be pushed
into bonded labor situation they can be
uh
victim of trafficking so they can also
be get into child marriages and also
they can be pushed into sex trade
the same age as rustam pyle used to go
rack picking to a nearby railway station
to help earn for her family before the
lockdown
for young girls of homeless families a
rare shot at education
also takes a back seat as domestic
responsibilities take over
pyle dropped out of school to help out
her family after her brother passed away
though she got enrolled in an open
learning program
she does not have regular access to
books and stationery
sometimes she has to step out and beg
for money
we can take them to the open shelter or
or to
children home but ultimately unless
there is a livelihood protection
of these families unless there is
nutrition unless there's medical
treatment unless there's some form of
cash in their hands these children by
and large will continue to see on the
streets
for these three children the future
holds no certainty
and the current situation in the country
has made matters
worse for them
now there are many more aspects to this
pandemic
and it's time for your questions now is
our science correspondent derek williams
will vaccines work for young children or
be tailored for adults
this question addresses one of the
reasons why it's it's a good thing to
have so
many different teams working on on so
many different vaccines
um there's a widely acknowledged problem
with testing not only vaccines but
but new therapies in general which is
that
early trials in particular are usually
conducted
on groups of healthy adults under 65
and of course um they aren't the people
who need it most
with cobit 19 elderly men with
co-morbidities are the group
that's most at risk but especially in
early
safety and efficacy trials nobody
will be trying vaccine candidates out on
that group
because not only could it be dangerous
it could also
skew the data and lead researchers to
false conclusions
the same holds true for testing new
vaccines in children
it can be risky because you can't just
treat them like little adults they
they can react differently to vaccines
it's certainly possible if not likely
that
children and adults will be vaccinated
differently
when and if they become available
you